well it's not just what they're saying
it's what they believe
yeah like no no and that's a bigger
problem because people act on beliefs
bro this is the perfect two-year-old
toddler tantrum mentality you see that
video of the woman fong on the ground
and screaming because she was being
filmed no but i've heard of it
exemplifies millennials for the most for
the most part unfortunately not all
millennials are bad we seem to be good
people you guys seem to be good people
but what happens is
cuban people are in revolution saying
down with dictatorship libertad and then
aoc is like america should give them
free stuff
yeah what aoc
no no no no no no aoc you give them your
free stuff yeah there you go do it
yourself don't do it with somebody
else's stuff just do it yourself i just
looked this up it's july 26 1953 was the
beginning of the cuban revolution it
ended january 1st 1959 so about a
six-year revolution that is after 1946
which is when the liberal economic order
was established basically the
military-industrial complex that
eisenhower told us about and it's
possible that america was
suppressing the hell out of that country
in what way i really don't know it's a
conspiracy at this point like force and
i were talking about conspiracy theories
and the kind of
the problem with them is that you want
to believe something is true because it
gives you a sense of empowerment to be
like i get it yeah so there's something
good about me that i understand
so first and foremost i think
people should be responsible for
themselves
like yeah i i look i i believe in
charity i like social programs
but people are responsible for
themselves to it to a great degree
if you don't have food
i may be a good person and help you but
if you give a man a fish you feed him
for a day if you're teaching a man a
fish you feed him for the rest of his
life in the end if i ultimately say bro
you like there's a homeless guy outside
and he's like let me sleep in your house
and i'm like no you are causing my
suffering it is your fault then
activists jump and they're like the only
reason this man is suffering is because
tim poole won't let him in his house
it's like no the dude is responsible for
his own shelter man to a point but the
french revolut no literally two periods
but if there's a a monarch that's that's
hoarding all the materials so that the
people are starving and suffering it is
the monarch's fault why because he's
by force keeping them from their stuff
or what the stuff that they their
community has produced so can they like
leave
it depends i mean is the king you can't
even
um
leave
actually is a good question because
where are you going to go are you going
to go west right
you go in the middle of the woods oh
yeah i mean that works
with us my point is about cuba
cuba's food problem is cuba's problem
cuba's medicine problem is cuba's
problem there is no obligation from any
other country to give to them yes and it
is not america's fault they don't have
stuff and in the cold war when you side
against our enemies we are not obligated
to feed you when your social experiment
fails yeah we had a cuban missile crisis
it's the same thing with conservatives
it's like you know they're not obligated
to
not conservatives it's like okay let's
let's use a really good example like i
mean you know a lot of people even rag
on iron rand's argument through uh
atlas shrugged it's like at some point
in time the people providing are going
to stop doing it and then your arguments
your high high-handed you know moral
arguments on the greatest good for the
greatest number won't mean a thing
that's exactly it let's say america
didn't exist at all
oh no cuba can't trade to get food from
america because there isn't one
to be entirely fair american foreign
policy has not always had the highest
end goals in mind we see that in the
middle east i don't know enough about
cuba and the embargo there i'm just
saying that i don't really trust the
us's
like high-handed ascertains of what
they're doing anymore bro these these
these commies they communism comes to
being when entitled
people think they are owed things and
then want to take them from you i
actually disagree with you on that one
you don't think that's where communism
comes from i think communism comes from
your your
the
i think i think communism comes from a
base morality of selfishness i just
wanted that's i i don't think it's
entitlement i think well i think
entitlement is this thing of like there
are there are things owed to me
perhaps because i exist or because of of
of other things i think i think when
communism is born out of malice it's i
don't like you and i'm better than you
and if i believe this i'm holier than
you you know i mean authoritarianism
maybe but that's like what you're the
point of what's the difference between
communism and authoritarianism communism
is communism is literally about the
ownership by the community meaning you
have people who are like i should that
should be mine
so it's the about like marxism the
abolishment of private property right no
it's not owned by the by the commons by
the people it's not the [ __ ] it never
functions it's not the abolishment of
private property it's the abolishment of
your property for my benefit yeah yeah
yeah but if you look at the things like
if you look what aoc is saying you look
at what the squad is talking about and
things like that they're basically
saying other people have things that i
want and i should they should be given
to me yeah so we are saying the same
thing but i i think i think it's
fundamentally not born out of like an
intellectual deficiency i think it's
fundamentally borne out of a moral
defense i agree with you yeah yeah these
people have never lifted a heavy object
in their lives communism ends in mass
murder always because it requires
absolute uh what do you call it
um everyone needs to do it willingly if
if one objector exists then this the
entire system collapses because we all
pull our resources you get you give all
your resources you give all of yours
lydia gives all of hers i give all of
mine but then i go wait no i want to
keep this
that act alone now the only thing that
you can do is either dissolve the whole
system because it broke or you have to
kill me
it requires well gulag or steal your
stuff well i got really loud there for
you yeah i mean but why does it why does
it always fail in that same manner it's
because it requires absolute
volunteerism if you have one person who
says no i don't think so for good reason
or evil it doesn't matter
i don't want to be a part of your
experiment for whatever reason by their
own choice
it it fails at that moment that's why
right libertarianism right
libertarianism is the best
if the united states elected an actual
right libertarian a dave smith for
instance and he was like i'm going to
leave you alone and do your thing
then the hippies could have their
commune the left libertarians i think
was ron paul who said it's like in
america you can create your own comm you
know i'm stopping you it's that these
people want your stuff that's what
they're actually doing they want you to
uphold them when their system fails
there there is there i think there's
more than one successful communes they
have about 100 people and they don't
allow to go larger than that so you can
apply to join and then as soon as
someone leaves next in line gets
admitted into the commune everybody has
jobs and you all live and everything's
shared but there are people who own it
and run it
so there's still authority who was it
that was saying that all the most
successful communes have been christian
or religious based is that true i think
yesterday's something yeah yeah
somebody's mentioning throughout the
trip throughout history yeah then you
also have things like the gnostics but
they kind of died in the desert
if everybody believes in the same
ideology then your commune works yeah
because you all you have a you have a
shared sense of belief you can't you
can't have communism and
multiculturalism right you can't have
communism and you know like it just it's
fundamentally incompatible with
basically all of humans well actually i
mean honestly i think that uh a
functioning country probably needs some
kind of religion yes
how deep do you want to go into the
definition of religion yeah money is it
needs a shared ideology yeah it needs it
needs a share so if a religion is not so
much a belief in like a supernatural god
but rather a hierarchy of values again a
moral framework a moral frame so my
religion is the what i call a religion
is the hierarchy of values whatever's at
the top of that is my god so if i am
calling myself an atheist i'm also
calling myself god because it is my mind
that determines everything that is real
and so it's sort of it's sort of it's my
mind that determines what's right and
wrong for some if i don't use something
outside of me to inform me on what is
right and wrong i am saying my mind is
the ultimate authority on right and
wrong at least within my existence and i
don't think that's a completely
unrespectable position you just need to
be humble and honest and realize that's
what it is and so yeah a religion is a
ordered a hierarchy of values and if a
culture doesn't have a unified
hierarchy of values how would it work
together right
multi-ideologism doesn't work i like
that word
salad though multi-ideology is a word
yeah i like it so in the u.s having a
bunch of different ideologies doesn't
work no well yeah i mean i know
what does mean to work you know i mean
it provides opportunity to debate things
that's for sure true
well it doesn't work in the sense that
without social cohesion it balkanizes no
yeah exactly everyone fights each other
in a way the us dollar i think is modern
religion i mean bro look at look at look
at the the child drag shows
like come on like there is a hard line
for for a lot of regular people but the
left supports the child stripping 100
they defend at every turn probably on
tribal grounds because they don't
actually care because they have no more
like
this is the funniest thing i think a lot
of conservatives need to realize not
just conservatives but like
i don't know what you call that leftist
group okay because i'm fairly
revolutionary in a lot of respects like
i want to change i think the country
needs to change a whole lot i'm not like
federal reserve get it out of there you
know conservatives were like stop we're
gonna keep things the same i'm like you
know let's change it all
but i think i draw the line with the
kids stripping for money at the very
least and what a lot of people who are
in the culture war right don't
understand is
these people don't share your values at
all there's a video of a four-year-old
twerking and they're all laughing and
clapping and cheering as that happens
yeah there are people in this country
that value stripping you of your
your right to own a firearm as a good
thing they don't think of it as a means
to an end they think of it as a good
thing yeah you shouldn't have a gun
period yeah it doesn't matter like you
you they they view you as sub-human if
it's a human right to own a firearm and
they say you don't have the right you're
they're viewing you as sub-human the
only reason
it's all this way with it with the child
stripping
why aren't uh people like running like
why aren't there armed men shutting down
child stripping and grooming shows why
aren't people in new york going up and
being like stop what you're doing to
this four-year-old child right now put
that camera away and stop this twerking
in new york they overwhelmingly have the
same moral framework
they like it they celebrate it and the
people who don't are probably leaving
like could you imagine somebody who is
you know probably like
take somebody who's you know
probably opposed to the rioting in black
lives matter someone who's pro-2a but
would choose to live in minneapolis like
they'd have to be a psychopath right
thanks
right
well i did read a book once that
confirmed it so i guess i'm a psychopath
now there you go thanks grossman yeah
you're a hero
i'm only half kidding i mean people are
leaving people are leaving the city i
don't want to live in this place i can't
imagine this
as we move down this path to where you
get prominent progressive channels with
millions of followers praising and
defending child stripping i'm like
that's not going to last because when
you have like with the james younger
case in texas where a dad says my son is
my son and the mom says my son is
actually my daughter and is trans at a
certain point a parent is going to be
like do not touch my child yeah and then
and then what
i mean it'll change when parents
actually value their children you know
like we talk about the public school
system right
this is i mean this is that i've used
this example a couple times before but
it's my classic frustration is you have
a middle class dad
a father and he has a kid who's in
public school and that father every time
you see him all you're going to hear him
do is rail against the public school
system while he works his nine to five
and his kid goes to the public schools
system and so for 18 years you just hear
the same thing public school system blah
blah blah then susie turns 18 and dad
takes 140 thousand dollars that he has
saved up and sends susie to college
where he continues to complain and she
ends up a communist and hates him yeah
what like you failed as a father i saw i
think it was a reddit post where a guy
was like my daughter came back you know
for for a break for like spring break or
something and when she left she was a
normal you know high school kid
graduated now her head's shaven she's
wearing weird makeup and she tells me
she hates me and i'm evil it's like yeah
well pay attention i'll tell you this
man this idea that
parents had where it's like i can ignore
what my child's
my my child's life is like what they're
being taught and what they're being
indoctrinated with i can ignore the the
raising of my child and they'll be okay
psychotic yes people are people care
more about their their their pet's life
than their child their their child has
become a pet that they put up with and
they you know feed it and then whatever
but like i think that's very serious i i
have to say this with with absolute like
seriousness
family raising and raising a family is
that your most important responsibility
as a as a parent
i guess i have to say this
not having kids yet of my own but is to
pass your values onto your children so
that they will be
you know so that if because if they're
your values you believe in them right so
and maybe they want their kids to be
commies who hate them no i mean it's
it's the same thing like if let's just
say i have a any insert any value if i
believe that the second amendment is a
moral value i don't think that people
owning firearms is a utility against an
uh
against a foreign government or or
against corruption in argument i don't i
don't believe it is a utility argument
although it could have one i think that
owning a firearm firearms ownership on
the citizen level is fundamentally a
moral problem
it is moral that people say this is my
country i have investiture in it it is
my land i am a part of it i am part of
this country therefore i take personal
responsibility within my community to be
able to do that so if i think that's a
value and then i have a kid and say you
believe whatever you want man i don't
want you i don't want to push my beliefs
on you
you don't believe those things they're
just a fashion statement to you you kind
of just passed that belief on to me
because if we were in a tribe 7 000
years ago and there were wild animals
trying to attack and kill the tribe if
you were if you didn't pick up a spear
and attack and defend you were acting
immorally
it is your moral duty as a human to
produce a weapon and defend your tribe
from
that's kind of why we're seeing what
we're seeing i suppose but it's the
government's monopoly on violence that i
think is keeping everything in check
because i'll tell you this man there's
probably a lot of people who are more
traditionalist and not even necessarily
far right or even that particularly that
conservative who are looking at what's
going on with the abuse of children in
this country particularly in cities and
their eyes are probably twitching and
veins are throbbing
and it's scary stuff i mean
how can this country survive i see this
this poll about the balkanization you
know 37.2 percent want to want to uh
want to break apart and i say i get it i
watch that video of that kid stripping
for money at
a club with men throwing money at them
and i totally understand why people say
get new york and la out of my country
because what else do you do about it
i don't know i'm legislating federally
led i don't know
more more local law that's a culture
issue they that what you're talking
about is a call no no um city council
came together and said we're going to
make a child a child strip in front of
other people that was a cultural
decision and those people do not have
your culture and their culture is an
opposition of yours it's incompatible
right you're running the the the great
the the i'm going to use this as
sarcastically as possible this great
idea that all roads lead to rome that
all religions are just the same
is ridiculous because all of them
describe evil in completely different
ways i i think it's funny there's like
this weird meme where people keep
calling me an atheist and i don't know
where that came from what well you're
you're agnostic you're a thief no i'm
not i believe in god okay he's a theist
i'm kind of agnostic oh yeah i am a no
i'm not i'm not theistic in the sense
that it follows script or anything like
that but i believe in god how do you
fall in this realm or for like religious
yeah yeah you'd call it i'm a reformed
christian yeah what does that mean uh so
reformed is somewhat follows from the
tradition of calvin and there's there's
i mean you can go multiple different
ways but think of it as like within the
christian
within what people refer to as
christianity there are certain things
that are sort of necessary doctrine so
when you talk about praxis that's a that
comes from a religious concept of
practice
doxy doctrine versus praxis practice
practice you know so orthodoxy how what
what is the
the accepted belief in orthopraxy what
is the accepted practice so for me one
of the things is in the tension between
the
um and the tension between human free
will and the sovereignty of god right so
if god knows all things
is all powerful and is outside of time
do we really have free will
i think it's i think that free will is
something i live as though i have free
will but according to doctrine i think
that the sovereignty of god is much more
important i think it's much more closer
to being true
so that means did you see that lightning
strike bro
yeah the uh i heard about it those that
the george floyd mural getting struck by
lightning
blowing out the brick wall
i checked the weather on that day and it
was sunny with scattered clouds
in the photos the ground was mostly dry
which is to insinuate it rained very
briefly
just enough for a lightning strike on
the george floyd mural
that that's freaky stuff a lot of people
were saying it was a sign got it spoken
there's memes of a hand coming out of
clouds with a gun and i'm like you know
look sometimes lightning strikes
buildings happens actually all the time
and this one happened to have a george
floyd mirror on it the agnosticism in me
really shows as one person told me hey
one lightning strike doesn't prove
anything and i thought well it doesn't
disprove it either that's true yeah well
what's the chance that the lightning
would strike a building
and blow out or focusing on a lot
not
if the human mind is a bunch of
electrical magnetic
i've seen some stuff man like i'll tell
you if there was one thing that really
like
snapped something in my head it was
watching that kid strip on stage
and the left cheering for and clapping
and seeing that four-year-old little
girl twerking and they're cheering for
it and i'm like
dude i am like left lib hippie on a farm
live and let live be happy and they're
they're doing these things to kids like
there is evil in this world man then
that lightning strike with everything
i've seen i'm like man you know
okay
can you just can you finish how you were
about to say something about that
dichotomy between orthodoxy and ortho oh
not the dichotomy between orthodoxy and
proxy but the tension between human free
will and the sovereignty of god so like
so our the question is are humans
actually do we have free will and like
we think so like we generally think so
but from like a theological doctrine
it's these two uh concepts exist in
tension and so
while i so what i would say is i believe
and i believe that
um god is sovereign as in like
everything from gravity is the continual
action of god we are living through
god's continual process of creation
um and so in some ways it's determined
but we're not capable of seeing in that
and the measurement or the the mechanism
of its determination being determined is
bigger than our capacity to observe
gravity
all of reality because of in the
beginning god created the heavens and
the earth right so if god created then i
don't think that he created the earth
and just said okay cool let's see how
this experiment plan plays out i think
that the act that we're seeing the world
that we're seeing right now is he's
continuously upholding the world as it
is so the the professor of mine that i
studied under said salt dissolves in
water every time the same time because
god is consistent and each and he you by
his will has salt dissolve in water
every time exactly the same way he that
what we call laws of nature are just his
continual action
so that's that's on a metaphysics level
and then from like historical and and i
be what i believe evil is so the problem
of evil how can a all-perfect god
all-knowing god and our all-powerful
all-knowing and all-good god create a
world where there's evil this is not a
very intelligent question people usually
use it as a stumping question it's not a
very intelligent question because people
have been answering it for 2 000 years
if you're just coming to that now and
you don't read a book you're not asking
the question honestly i'm just going to
jump to the table it's a difficult
question and multiple theologians have
answered it over the time but the one
that i fall under is that evil is the
absence of god so man
sin entered the world as human kinds
humankind sinned against god and they
became less than they were intended to
so it's the absence of god if god is the
source of life he's the source of all
these other things so that's kind of and
that's on on on what is evil what is
good good
god writes the laws of morality in the
same way that he writes the laws of
science they're absolute we just think
of laws in human creations where i can
break a human law and get away with it
but you can't break the law of god and
get away with it so do you think that
like that lightning strike is god coming
back to the scene in some way or
something no i i don't i don't you think
just sometimes lightning strikes yeah i
don't i don't i think it's very
dangerous to
pretend that me a human can interpret
something as the will of god when he
gave us scripture
and now and and we have and that's hard
enough for me to comprehend i'm so i
don't i do believe that god acts in our
world i'm just very very very skeptical
when i see something happen so that
because i don't want to get caught up in
this this
storm of like
for lack of better words i don't want to
i don't think it's respectful for even a
theological sense to
interpret everything as if it's like oh
god is speaking to me
i think that's a little dangerous is it
taking psychedelics no
but to be consistent if the act of salt
dissolving in water is the process of
god using like his power to make it
happen like continuing a scientific
process then how would it not be
consistent to say that something like a
lightning strike could be interpreted as
god moving and acting let me rephrase
myself then yes you're correct in that i
will i will see that point yes it is god
chose that to happen at that point at
that time in that place right my i
however i don't necessarily
i think i need to be
humble in recognizing is that that event
happening the significance of it is so
that i will think something or i will
see it is it a sign is the question i'm
saying and i'm very very cautious about
seeing things as signs because those are
things that you have to take very
seriously for example if you see you
know if i say god spoke to me
and told me to do something or whatever
and i don't do it i am either lying or
that is an absolute sin because i have
irrefutable evidence within the
construct of my mind that he came to me
and said
drink that soda and i don't drink that
soda i'm just basically saying well you
are not god anymore i don't care and
it's ma it's a huge issue there but then
on on the flip side if you say that god
told me to do something and he did not
you are lying in my mind that is that is
the form that is literally speaking for
god that is taking god's name in vain
yeah very much so and so it's it's one
of those things where like for when you
when you address these issues from
a very serious level if you take your
faith seriously you will not be flippant
with lucid interpretations as if there
are signs specifically from god telling
you to do something because you will
take any you take interpretation very
very very seriously and that's where i
see the big difference in i used to take
signs too seriously it was driving me
slowly insane like i would see two birds
flying and i'd be like that means that i
will find love and it was like
you're going nuts crossland take a step
back he's become self-aware everyone
maybe from maybe there is a grand arcing
coercive plan but i don't know
i think it falls in the same line of
conspiracy theory in the sense of it it
produces some of the same effects it's
just a religious version of it because
like yeah when you're seeing everything
as the conspiracy of the illuminati you
go crazy because you're you lose your
ability to
accurately perceive to your own ability
the actual world because everything has
to be seen through the lines of the
conspiracy do you think god has in
functions with intention absolutely
yeah he's a person how would you define
intention
i i think we understand intention
because we understand that god has a
will i think i wouldn't i wouldn't say i
understand
my intention and i'm going to ascribe
that to god i think that
you and i to you and i we have an
intention because i have both desires
and when i when i pick up this magazine
i'm picking it up to do something when
i'm writing if my writing is not an act
of intention if i'm not creating out of
intent am i creating
no
and so
the act of creation itself is a sign of
intent
well there you go yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time